l'ancien conseiller spécial de nicolas
sarkozy à l'elysée est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous vous connaissez votre
baptême du feu électoral dans les villes
vous n'aimez pas tellement l'expression
en fait du feu ya pas le feu ça a pas le
feu
et ça n'est pas une guerre même temps un
train dans votre camp je pense à jean
françois copé se présente non chef de
guerre et c'est une image mais la
politique c'est pas léguer à sa totale
est très faible
en tous les cas je vous êtes candidat
dans une circonscription où apparemment
vous ne devriez pas avoir trop de
problème même s'il y a de nombreux
candidats autour de vous c'est la
présidence 19 system candidat vous et
l'ump
nadège peljak de l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire vous interrogera sur ce
thème tout à l'heure vous et nicolas
sarkozy chronique achevée par l'essec du
6 mai une injustice fut votre premier
mot je me souviens et perrine tarneaud a
beaucoup de questions à vous poser à ce
sujet
j'avais un sentiment d'injustice voilà
peut-être que vous l'avez vécu est
vraiment personnellement vous nous direz
pourquoi et comment vous est le nouveau
pouvoir bien c'est ce qui va nous
occuper au cours du premier quart
d'heure de cette émission rigano êtes
vous prêt à reconnaître que françois
hollande même s'il ne connaît pas d'état
de grâce dans l'est dans les sondages a
réussi son entrée dans le grand jeu
diplomatique internationale aux etats
unis
mais comment aurait-il pu en être
autrement je dire qu'un nouveau
président arrive sur la scène
internationale d'un président français
il est accueilli gentiment poliment
mêmes cordialement c'est tout à fait
normal
je les ai fait l'expérience d'expérience
valoir l'expérience elle va se mesurer
aux résultats pour l'instant on est dans
la
dans l'accueil mais dans les premiers
pas c'est normal que président français
soient bien accueillis
j'aurais trouvé détestable qu'il ne le
soit pas un effet d'image réussi à côté
d' obama et d'autres responsables
internationaux
et oui fait c'est normal je suis à côté
de banat facile à un sommet g8 wa sommet
de l'otan whif alors ça mais tout ça est
quelque chose de tout à fait naturel
c'est pas la preuve qu'on a une bonne
politique ni qu'on réussit mais c'est de
se se passe normalement comme elles
doivent se passer d'accord alors c'est
très bien ainsi
seulement une question d'image le
journal allemand bild voit le président
français donc à l'offensive roulant non
même prendre le commandement à enghien
la merkel c'est comme ça que vous le
voyez vous aussi dans son enfance et
notamment sur la barre je sais pas
quelles sont ces ses arrière pensées mes
jeux l'europe ne peut pas se construire
sur la volonté de l'un de l'autre de
commander à personne ne commandent en
europe il faut que chacun fasse des pas
vers l'autre voilà et c'est la seule
manière
malheureusement certains pensent que
merkel landes sera couple plus équilibré
que merkozy ou manuelle notre équilibre
ce couple on a beaucoup dit que en gala
merkel avait réussi à imposer sa volonté
non c'est tout ça et ce sont des
caricatures des propos de campagne sinon
des propos de comptoir alors on s'est en
tous les cas coeur avec berlin ça va
coincer sur les euro-obligations la
solution que rejette la chancelière pour
sortir de la crise de l'euro mais
françois hollande a réussi quand même à
imposer la croissance à l'agenda est
aujourd'hui et beaucoup de responsables
européens finalement sont satisfaits de
voir le président français à tenir un
autre discours face à la chancelière et
vous rigolez non si la france tienne
discours de la croissance depuis
toujours
voilà pendant toute la crise la france a
tenu le discours de la croissance c'est
une cette absurde mais simplement on va
très vite constaté que personne n'est
d'accord sur la manière de faire de la
croissance en europe et de relancer
l'activité
c'est mai
heureusement qu'on est pour la
croissance pourquoi vous l'être pour la
décroissance pour la dépression pour la
récession enfin personne mais il est
assez fou pour ce pour cela la question
de savoir à quels moyens on se donne
pour fabriquer de la croissance est ce
que vous estimez que d'ores et déjà le
bilan de nicolas sarkozy est attaqué par
certaines décisions ministérielles
est-ce que vous condamnez par exemple le
laxisme supposé de christiane taubira
qui est en quelques jours est devenu à
droite la tête de turc préférées bon
c'est pas facile de supposer elle a dit
qu'elle voulait moindre impression bande
de donc moins de sanctions
moi je suis totalement opposé à
l'impunité voilà je pense que quand y'a
pas d'impunité on peut pas combattre la
délinquance on peut pas combattre les
voyous et surtout je vois pas comment
nous pouvons éduquer nos enfants si on
fait de l'impunité un grand principe de
la république mais simplement est là et
la vie qu'elle allait mettre un terme
aux tribunaux correctionnels pour les
mineurs et bien si tu laisses édifice
une faute grave
voilà ce une faute grave de ne pas
vouloir réformer la justice des mineurs
pour ce parce que ça c'est une c'est une
erreur profonde voilà parce que la
délinquance des mineurs a beaucoup
évolué depuis l'après guerre et qui
elles ne fonctionnent pas de façon
satisfaisante aujourd'hui alors est ce
qu'on va nous allons laisser toute une
jeunesse en perdition à la dérive pour
parce qu'on ne veut toucher à rien par
conservatisme ou par corporatisme pour
faire plaisir à quelques juges pour
enfants qui estiment évidemment que tout
est parfait qui font leur métier le
mieux possible maintenant mais au fil
des voyous si si si si tout se passe
très bien vous ne pouvez pas avoir un
côté un ministre de l'intérieur un qui
dit l'ordre la sécurité et de l'autre
côté un ministre de la justice qui dit
surtout ne punissons pas ne sanctionnant
pas ne touchons à rien on à la justice
ne fonctionne pas bien
peut-être peut-être un grand débat
national que nous devrions avoir envoyé
l'as déjà les prémices d'un clivage
entre manuel valls et que les iem tobias
est ce que tout le monde voudrait
participer mais là il ya quelque chose
de très gênant avoir d'un côté quelqu'un
qui veut la sécurité de nous a assez dit
pendant la campagne que la gauche enfin
s'était converti à la nécessité
d'assurer la sécurité de
de nos concitoyens et puis de l'autre
côté là où se joue aujourd'hui la partie
décisive c'est à dire sur la justice
avoir un ministre qui au fond presse
l'impunité et le laxisme
sous la pression d'un certain nombre de
corporatisme des magistrats publicité
mais eux mêmes disent que cette forme de
jugement devant les tribunaux
correctionnels pour pour mineurs mais
concernait que quelques centaines
d'individus par vous savez est ce que
cela va donner la valeur d'exemple
d'abord elle devance ainsi la
délinquance des mineurs
c'est celle d'un noyau dur de ce petit
noyau dur qui empoisonnent la vie de
tout le monde qui donne le mauvais
exemple qui entraîne les autres et qui
pourrit la vie de nos concitoyens
je pense que c'est un sujet dont il faut
s'occuper
alors que la solution des tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs mérite pour
combien vaut réfléchissent peut-être
mais il faut absolument réformer la
justice des manières on se trouve là
face à un gouvernement qui ne veut pas
toucher à la justice des mineurs alors
mais on ne va pas bien il faut se méfier
aussi des effets d'annoncé par exemple
on a découvert aujourd'hui que la
suspension des allocations familiales
pour absentéisme scolaire n'avait touché
que 472 foyer or il y a dit on dans
notre pays trois cent mille enfants
décrocheurs non mais vous savez là ce
qui est extraordinaire avec cette mesure
c'est qu'elle a permis de ramener
beaucoup d'enfants sur le chemin de
l'école est effectivement le seul fait
qu'elles existent a suffi être une
incitation très forte à ramener
énormément d'enfants à l'école et c'est
très bien que l on était obligé en fait
de suspendre les allocations que dans un
très petit nombre de cas elle a donc
parfaitement fonctionné parfaitement
le but c'est pas que tout le monde les
allocations 6e
un fan vient soit suspendue pour portes
pour tous les enfants qui ne vont pas à
l'école c'est qu'au contraire il y ait
de moins en moins d'enfants qui qu'ils
soient enfants de l'école et c'est cette
mesure a très bien fonctionné
l'association des amis de nicolas
sarkozy va voir le jour les statuts vont
être déposés là incessamment sous peu
est ce que vous allez en faire partir en
can you know bien entendu comment il
pouvait vous imaginez que vous ne fasse
pas partie des amis de nicolas sarkoy
avec l objectif défendre le bilan
non d'abord c'est une d'abord c'est une
association d'amis comme son nom
l'indiqué c'est à dire qu'elle est
d'abord fondée sur l'amitié sur les
liens profonds qui ont été tissés entre
nous pendant des années d'une tâche à la
fois difficile et exaltante
c'est d'abord une affaire de sentiments
et puis évidemment on défendra le le le
bilan en ce qui a été accompli qu'elle
nous avons six autres participé avec
l'ailé de vente seulement faire pression
sur nicolas sarkozy pour qu'il ne quitte
pas le le combat politique c'est une
association d'amis si gérard il devient
dépression elle serait tout à fait
d'accord la première mesure du
gouvernement fut la baisse des salaires
des réminiscences et que celles du
président et du premier ministre va
suivre ce que vous approuvez
non non moins 30%
non non je joue je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de démagogie dans cette mesure
d'abord imaginé nous sommes en face
d'une crise planétaire d'une crise
européenne la grèce l'espagne italie
portugal et les difficultés des français
est alors croyez vous qu'en baissant le
salaire des ministres et du président de
la république et du premier ministre va
y avoir moins de pauvres en france il va
y avoir moins de chômeurs que la crise
va être résolue que le pouvoir d'achat
est partagé mais si on décide de
diminuer les salaires des fonctionnaires
je trouve normal qu'on diminue les
salaires des ministres et du président a
vu enfin pour l'instant on n'a pas
diminué les salaires des fonctionnaires
on augmente les charges augmentent les
impôts on demande sa fille ça tout le
monde le ministre paie aussi mais aussi
des impôts je trouve que désigne
ainsi les ministres comme des gens qui
roulerait sur l'or qui jouirait de
privilèges exorbitants et quelque chose
qui me gêne profondément voilà qui n'est
pas conforme à ma vision de la
république parce que ce sera toujours
trop ou savez c'est très facile d'agiter
ce genre de deux sentiments dans la dans
la population
pour quelqu'un qui gagne le smic qui a
du mal à finir ses fins de mois ce sera
toujours trop évidemment évidemment et
donc on ne sera jamais assez le salaire
des ministres
alors pourquoi 30% j'ai dit en forme de
boutade ça en a irrité certains mais
c'est bien pourquoi pas 50 60 en fait
pourquoi pas la gratuité et allons au
bout de la plaisanterie ne la réclame
vous ne savez pas jusqu'où on va les
gars mais je propose qu'elle soit
gratuite
et puis que on ne confie ses fonctions
qu'à des gens qui ont une fortune
suffisante pour en assumer la charge
c'était comme cela que ça se passait
sous l'ancien régime voilà non je je
trouve que c'est très dangereux pour la
démocratie de faire des responsables
politiques
les boucs émissaires de la crise voilà
et c'est un peu ce qu'il ya derrière
cette mesure
et puis vous savez peut-être que ça
annonce des sacrifices plus importants
qui sont demandés aux autres aussi donc
les français devront se méfier de ce que
de ce que cela présage pour la suite
et puis vous savez quand on n'est pas
décidé à agir concrètement pour
améliorer le sort des gens et bien on se
contente de satisfaction symbolique
voilà celle là est sans doute la plus
mauvaise qu'on pouvait imaginer je sais
que ce que je dis n'est pas forcément
populaires mais c'est ma position morale
et je la défendrai au lancement et la
mort ailleurs je crois que vous avez pu
rêver dans le passé henri guaino d'une
présidence d'une grande société publique
et la jeune et rêvait de rien du tout
mais très longtemps une dizaine de
candidatures effectivement une
présidence entre pressions que c'était
il ya très longtemps alors aujourd'hui
l'éventail des salaires va être réduit
dans ces entreprises où l'état est
présent en parle d'un éventail de 1 à 20
la vous le condamnez également au nom de
la morale mais vous lui sans la mesure
au nom de la morale mais vous savez la
morale elle a bon dos dans l'avion tout
ça je la sais même plus un problème de
morale c'est un problème d'efficacité et
des de rien
l'isthme jeu voilà pourquoi pourquoi de
la fin pourquoi pas de 1,30 ou dans la
case de 1 à 10 je veux dire que qui est
des salaires qu'ils peuvent parler d'
excuse pas à taxer s'y fait très bien on
peut on les diminue mais mais en faire
une règle générale absolue arithmétique
à quelque chose d'absurde c'est ce qu'il
faut c'est réformer le système
économique réformer la finance réformer
la société de façon à ce que les
rémunérations soient plus acceptables
plus légitimes parce que le système
économique fonctionne autrement mais s'y
attaquer de cette manière là encore une
fois me paraît désigné toujours pareil
des boucs émissaires et se satisfaire de
au fond de bien peu de choses parce qu'
il vaut mieux réformer le capitalisme
financier comme comme s'y était engagé
le président sarkozy comme il s'y est
employé pendant quatre ans même si c'est
difficile
plutôt que de prendre ce genre de mesure
voilà je ne suis pas je suis pas
dramatiquement opposé ce que l'on
réduise le campanile réagir oui c'est
trop bien c'est pas bien c'est une façon
de prendre les problèmes qui moi ne me
satisfait pas voilà mais alors autre
chose et elle est mêlée où monsieur
hollande a été élu pour ça donc tous
ceux qui ont voté pour lui ou qui ont
facilité son élection et bien sûr
doivent être très content de le voir
appliquer cette partie de son programme
mais excellent opus était ce vraiment ce
que les français attendent et ce qu'ils
attendent pas plutôt la hausse du
pouvoir d'achat la baisse du chômage la
sortie de terre il attend depuis des
années et bien voilà on nous a promis
qu'il suffisait d'arriver d'arrivée où
il part donc sur ce ne ne soyons pas ne
soyons pas caricatural président nicolas
sarkozy est arrivé et il s'est trouvé
confronté à une crise sans précédent
il a passé quatre ans à défendre le
pouvoir d'achat des français pour éviter
qu'ils ne s'effondrent
allez donc voir ailleurs à les voir en
espagne portugal en en irlande en italie
en grèce allait voir ce qui est devenu
le pouvoir d'achat dans ces pays où on a
baissé les salaires des fonctionnaires
parce qu'on est aimé de tous les
fonctionnaires
on a baissé les pensions de retraite
bien voilà nous sommes dans un pays où
les salaires des fonctionnaires ont pas
baissé ou les salaires en général n'ont
pas baissé et dans le statistiques on
voit même que le pouvoir d'achat s'est
maintenu même s'il ya des gens qui ont
beaucoup souffert de la crise c'est vrai
on a même conservé l'indexation des
pensions de retraite
c'est unique voilà donc peut pas dire
qu'il s'est pas battu pour le pouvoir
d'achat dans des circonstances qui
évidemment n'était pas prévisible quand
il est arrivé au pouvoir et que personne
au monde n'avait prévu estimez-vous
illégitime que le gouvernement par
décret modifie la réforme des retraites
en permettant à ceux qui ont travaillé
depuis l'âge de 18 ans par exemple se
foutent les partir à 60 ans le problème
n'est pas de savoir comment il va s'y
prendre en fonction leur accueil et le
président de l'assemblée juste que cette
démarche est contraire à la constitution
c'est une idée dans son vernis par des
crises a été dans son rôle lui en
vouloir à tout faire par décret tout
dépend maintenant de ce qui relève du
domaine de la loi ce qui relève du
domaine du règlement mais d'un art
accoyer dans son rôle
moi je pense que ce qui est le plus
important c'est de savoir si cette si
cette réforme de la réforme des
retraites est raisonnable ou pas si elle
est responsable parce que à la fin c'est
combien ça va coûter et qui va payer
qui va payer c'est ça la vraie question
maintenant c'est apporter tous les
salariés on sait bien voilà c'est la
cotisation augmenter dé très bien donc
donc le pouvoir d'achat va baisser donc
les charges sur le travail ont augmenté
donc la compétitivité va diminuer donc
il y aura plus de chômage et moins de
pouvoir d'achat
et bien c'est ça dont il faut discuter
alors on va en parler un peu plus tard
dans cette émission avant d'accueillir
nadège pull back de l' agence
france-presse
henri guaino on va vous suivre d'abord
est plutôt suivre mounir souci qui est
parti donc sur vos traces électorale
dans les yvelines
vous êtes donc candidat aux législatives
et vous avez notamment en face de vous
un maire ump qui avaient en moi même un
maire valérie mère qui revendique
l'investiture reprenant l'agent drame
pas là mais si tu re ça ça n'est pas
vrai ce n'est pas possible on va
l'écouter il intervient dans le sujet de
mounir ceci en fait nadège loin des
couloirs de l'elysée henri guaino fait
ses premiers pas dans sa nouvelle vie de
candidats si jamais rester enfermé dans
mon bureau je suis sorti ça allait voir
les jambes
j'adore voir des gens que ses premiers
contacts avec ses futurs électeurs même
s'il n'a pas encore tous les réflexes de
l'élu en campagne le courant passe dans
cette circonscription ancré à droite
il ya pas mal de dissidence ps qui se
créent au marquage il ya aussi des
dissidents ces mois là bas j'en ai j'ai
mon lolo l'a donc car son arrivée dans
les yvelines ne fait pas que des heureux
après le retrait du député sortant ce
maire en poste depuis 14 ans penser que
son tour était venu
mais dans la foulée de la défaite de
nicolas sarkozy l'ump a investi l'ancien
conseiller du président de la république
pour cet élu hors de question de
s'effacer il affrontera son rival
jusqu'au bout et des c'est un dissident
quel mépris qui est le diviseur qui est
le dissident est ce que c'est celui qui
est sur le terrain depuis des mois ou
est-ce que c'est celui qui décide comme
ça juste après les élections
présidentielles parce qu'il a pris
connaissance des bons résultats de la
circonscription et quiches audi et qui
me dit en gros pardon c'est ce que
disent les gens pousse toi de là que je
m'y mette
pour henri guaino l'important dans cette
élection ce n'est pas l'ancrage mais le
message c'est une campagne nationale noc
les thèmes les thèmes seront dans le
situeront dans le prolongement de la
campagne présidentielle
vais pas adapté mes convictions mes
idées mes valeurs en fonction du lieu où
je me tenais énormément
presse les médias un atout pour le
candidat l'ump face à ces dix huit
adversaires
aujourd'hui seuls face aux électeurs
celui qui écrivait dans l'ombre passe
enfin de l'autre côté du miroir
voilà on vous reconnaissez encore vivais
en campagne et henri guaino a déjà était
avec nous l'agencé france presse
danseurs nadège possession notre invité
sur mon bon monsieur guaino alors on
parler des législatives comme on l'a vu
dans le sujet là mais avant d'aborder
votre propre candidature j'aimerais vous
poser une question
l'ump aux législatives c'est 70 % de
candidats et 30% de candidates alors
j'ai une question très simple et très
direct l'ump est sa partie misogyne sept
questions biaisées sérieuse monsieur
gagnon c'est biaisé parce que jean
françois copé a très bien répondu à
cette question
quand vous avez beaucoup de sortants
vous pouvez mais oui mais c'est parfaite
et ce n'est pas leur dire écoutez aller
dehors allez je sais que c'est difficile
de faire ça si on annonce est passé pas
dit non vraiment c'est pas ma conception
non plus ni de la politique ni de la
morale en politique et des gens qui sont
sortants qui ont fait leur travail
qu'ils ont et vous allez leur dire
écoutez dehors parce que ceux qui sont
compétents qui ont fait leur travail qui
sont engagés mérite d'être reconduit
dans l'aréna sera la même chose ça va
dépendre du ça va dépendre du résultat
des élections les renouvellements ils se
font quand ils mènent sont en voilà et
effectivement ou jean françois copé l'a
bien dit diaz des rares elle a été faite
sans doute ya une dizaine d'années et
après il faut du temps il faut du temps
pour petit à petit redresser plus de
temps qu au ps en tous les cas pas
arrivé parce que je vais à c'était parce
que le ps est moins deux sortants tout
simplement vous tapez un manque de
volontarisme mois non non c'est parce
qu'il y avait moins deux sortants mémène
sortant mais c'est un problème de
volontarisme encore une fois c'est un
problème de principe au volontariat ça
consiste quand même pas à remercier dans
une coupe pied dans le derrière les gens
qui en tirant bien travaillé pendant des
années qui ont fait leur qui ont été
élus qui sont et qui s'en sort tant
qu'ils ont parfaitement vers la parité
par la loi ça doit pas être votre tasse
de thé henri guaino jamais de mal et les
quotas par la loi s'est jamais
mais la loi est là et qui est beaucoup
de femmes en politique je m'en réjouis
et s'il pouvait même y avoir plus de
femmes que d'hommes j'en serais ravie je
mens j'adore être entouré de femmes
je serai bien non je pense que nous
apporte beaucoup beaucoup de choses en
politique mais ça peut pas se faire par
le taux de là que je m'y mette je crois
qu on avait déjà entendu ce discours à
la fois d'avant mais bon écoutez on va
parler verlan à la fois d'avant
puisqu'il y avait beaucoup de rythme
mais j'ai compris votre également voir
un petit peu étonnant mais bon on va
parler d'autres candidats vous étiez
vous étiez candidat à un 3e
circonscription des yvelines
alors j'ai bien vu je vous ai écouté
j'ai vu voient leurs reportages vous
êtes très confiant mais comme c'est tout
je suis je suis votre confiance je vais
à la rencontre des électeurs comme
n'importe quel point deyda et c'est tout
moi c'est une circonscription d'une
façon de droite le 6 mai il y en a près
de 64% des électeurs ou accordé leur
confiance au président nicolas sarkozy
ben on est là pour vous ça sent quand
même pas trop gagné d'avancé il ya
dix-neuf candidats vous disiez tout à
l'heure
parmi eux il y en a 10 à droite il ya un
maire alors je ne sais pas dire l'ump
parce que vous allez me dernier il est
quand même
l'ex ump en tous les cas sur les bons et
vous y croyez quand même nous y croyez
je croyais pas gérer pavois je ne
présenterai pas enfin voila mais ce sont
les électeurs qui trancheront moi je
fais campagne mes convictions les
connaît mais mes idées on les connais je
vais voir les gens parler avec eux de
l'avenir de la france de la mère de leur
enfant
voilà et puis à la fin ils décideront
lequel est le mieux à même de les
représenter le kkl lequel il mieux à
même de porter leurs idées leurs
convictions dans le débat public à
l'assemblée nationale voilà quelle est
la voie la plus forte qui pourra se
faire en deux temps et faire entendre
leur voix
voilà c'est tout vous êtes arrivé
circonscription voulait proposer avait
peut-être des plus facile d'ailleurs où
vous avez la preuve dans tout cas on
pourra pas dire qu'elle est facile voilà
puisque regardez il ya dix-neuf
candidats il ya des dissidents
des gens qui racontent n'importe quoi
bon enfin vous les appelez distant le
pense que c'est vous le dissident on l'a
noté dans le reportage quand même arrivé
pour faire des bonnes chansons moi j'ai
demandé l'investiture tout à fait
normalement ma famille petit qui nous a
accordé vous savez celui qui ne respecte
pas cette règle est indécis dans le
dictionnaire voilà c'est fait dire que
c'est une affaire de de langue française
c'est pas une affaire d'opinion
d'accord ils ont qui considère toujours
que leur mandat leur appartient les voix
des électeurs leur appartiennent et puis
même les mandats qu'ils ont pas c'est à
eux
voilà là ce sont les électeurs qui
trancheront non mais alors on verra bien
mais on en attendait ce que vous croyez
vous une victoire possible de la droite
aux législatives mais une victoire est
toujours possible a encore son mot
français qui vont décider français ont
élu monsieur hollande maintenant ils
vont décider s'ils veulent que monsieur
jean d'application de la réhabilitation
c'est contraire à l'esprit de la 5ème
récemment la grève jeudi a raconté cette
histoire entre les deux tours des
élections présidentielles en 88 j'ai
rencontré michel debré
le père de notre constitution et j'avais
un peu le même sentiment la cohabitation
il m'a dit vous savez la cohabitation
elle est inscrite dans les institutions
est née dans l'esprit de nos
institutions c'est normal voilà c'est
dans les institutions de la vème
république la possibilité de la
cohabitation est inscrit prennent l'eau
keren l'action politique pour le moins
périodiques ses lacunes ça ne peut pas
se poser de cette manière elle pourrait
ne peut pas se poser de cette façon et
ça n'a aucun sens la question est la
seule question c'est que vont décider
les français je vais je vais faire
campagne pour des élections législatives
je vais pas dire aux gens surtout ne
votez pas pour moi ça donnerait la
cohabitation laisser monter suspects ont
donc
donc nous allons aux législatives pour
gagner voit très bien les accords
dollars au fus très bien là on se place
dans ce cas de figure vous gagnez vous
voyez qui à matignon mais d'abord il
faut gagner
et est ce que vous défendez alors la
question en fait normal avec soyons
clairs la l'ump la majorité sortante
avait un leader naturel qui s'appelait
nicolas sarkozy nicolas sarkozy a décidé
vous savez de se retirer de la vie
politique active de plus sollicité de
mandat depuis prendre de responsabilités
après les élections présidentielles donc
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de talent
dans ma famille politique je pense
surtout à l'hôtel non non il ya beaucoup
de talents leur sélection non non non je
ne vous répondrai pas comme ça vous
pouvez faire vos petites bon d'accord
des journalistes fij et non partisane et
la secrétaire général de l'ump c'est ça
c'est d'introduire la sienne donc c'est
le premier ministre a nié
il ya deux ans et demi il ya beaucoup de
gens c'est pas le le le c'est pas le
sujet moi je rentrais pas dans petite
histoire de journaliste à la revue des
cotisants ya bien je vais vous dire
comment les choses se passeront en cas
de cohabitation
le président de la république décidera
d'appeler quelqu'un à matignon temps
qu'il désignera celui qui lui paraît à
ses yeux le plus légitime le plus
représentatif et puis ensuite la
majorité dira s'ils la valident ce choix
si elles le valide c'est celui là qui
entraîne un procès oui mais c'est là
vous vous ne vous posez qu'ils en aient
voulu suggérer ce que vous avez une
préférence entre non monsieur copé et
monsieur fillon n'en ou encore peut-être
mais pas dans le mur ans non non vous
n'avez pas répondre non je n'ai pas de
préférence je me sens n'est pas le sujet
du jour et je n'avais pas sera fait
comme ça parce que voulait parce qu'on
vous les aimez tous les deux tout sympa
son jeu l'adorent tout le monde mais non
c'est pas ça n'a aucun sens je vais pas
jouer les arbitres des élégances c'est
le prix ce mois les incidents de la vème
république vous l'avez rappelé le me
tiennent beaucoup pas que c'est le
président lui qui choisit le premier
ministre libre à la majorité après de ne
pas lui accorder sa confiance ni dix et
kim kim et c'est pas une question
d'idées c'est le président de la
république qui décidera moi j'accepterai
rien ne sera donnée par le président de
la république et par la majorité
voilà est légitime il sait très bien où
est ce que je vais pas c'est ridicule
si tous les gens qui ouvrent ce débat
aujourd'hui pouvait se taire eh bien ça
rendrait un grand service à notre
famille politique
voilà aller au barça allait
nécessairement service à la campagne
président à la campagne mais pas
complètement sorti de votre corps va y
revenir on va y revenir la démocratie le
temps viendra
rassurez-vous de toutes les compétitions
de toutes les concurrences et du choix
après des militants de de la thématique
choisie leurs leaders sont alors vous
avez un petit peu abordé le sujet avec
avec michel méthot même monsieur jean
françois copé a parlé quand même deux
chefs de guerre il s'est dit je suis le
chef de guerre alors vous avez dit tout
à l'heure c'est pas guerrier ma chance
et un petit peu guerrier quand même
comme un coq comme expression et samedi
prélasser les français les français peut
de se poser là on a eu quand même une
campagne qui a été longue
un petit peu distrait parfois rude avec
ses rues sont toujours les campagnes
présidentielles alors une ferme cette
expression je rêve de guerre ah oui les
précédents est-ce qu'il ne suiviez
c'était dur vous sentez peut-être dans
les yvelines quand vous faites du
terrain une peut-être une forme de
lassitude des français qui ont envie de
voir le gouvernement gouverner le
président président et le diront le dire
on le dit mais le 10 juin et le 17 juin
ces sites viraux ce qu'ils en pensent
mais il ya une campagne législative que
voulez-vous que je vous dise c'est lé là
c'est pas moi qui les ai inventées c'est
la constitution bon il faut désigner
maintenant une majorité il faut bien
qu'ils aient une campagne bon c'est pas
par pegi est ce que vous pensez que le
front national peut mettre en danger
l'ump je sais qu'il va y avoir des
triangulaires oui mais si on peut
maintenir des candidats ça mettra en
danger nos candidats mais je pense que
la réponse à ça c'est pas de faire des
alliances avec les uns ou avec les
autres y aura pas d'alliance avec le fn
non non il n'y en aura pas mais c'est
pas l'ump peut résister au front
national parce que
deuxième tour de la présidentielle on a
vu qu'ils avaient 72 % des électeurs de
marine le pen qui s'étaient reportés sur
nicolas sarkozy
alors ça veut dire qu'il ya des
forcément des passerelles entre les deux
des passes à l'est d'alger que bien sûr
heureusement que les électeurs des uns
et des autres ne sont pas captif ainsi
non démocratie elle pouvait pas
fonctionner ces deux personnes
les votes d'apartheid à aucun parti vous
ne voyez pas en germe quand même la
recomposition de la droite que vous
contestez effectivement vous mettez en
garde nos amis peut-être mais je pense
que le problème pas ce mot de la droite
mais on va dire alors la famille de la
majorité sortante sera peut-être la
majorité de demain ou qui sera
l'opposition soit pour son problème
c'est de se reconstruire dont
idéologiquement donc on se sait si c'est
sa conviction
l'identité nationale par exemple ou le
pronom où la question des frontières moi
j'ai sarkozy a beaucoup parlé ou la
question maintenant c'est alors les
frontières c'est pas mais c'est marrant
quand résiste de philosophe de gauche
régis debray flâner sur les frontières
tout le monde ya bien des cas la
récupération sa thématique uns parlent
jamais de snobisme et de il l'a dit mais
si j'ai fait un débat avec ce sujet donc
voila moi j'ai moi je sujet des
frontières j'ai pas l'ombre d'une
divergence avec régis debray et se plie
avec s'est défendue par nicolas sarkozy
sur les frontières notamment dans son
discours toulouse était très très
conforme très conforme à ce que disais
aussi régis debray est ce qu'ils
défendent est après ce sont des procès
d'intention mais là on est
l'enjeu de cette famille politique de ce
fait majorité-opposition de demain c'est
d'être la plus forte possible à mieux
armé intellectuellement moralement et
quand elle est forte le front national
est faible mais elle n'a pas cessé pour
ne trouverez pas d'issue dans la
recomposition des alliances des accords
des combinaisons mais uniquement dans la
force morale intellectuelle et politique
de cette famille de cette famille mais
voilà c'est c'est ça la priorité à leurs
questions j'ai une petite question
alors certains candidats ump ne veulent
pas de l'étiquette ump sans affiches
électorales alors vous monsieur guaino
est ce que vous allez max l'utica de
l'ump oui mais bien sûr je m étais moi
qui suis sympa je suis pas un grand
maniaque des partis mais moi j'assume ma
famille politique j'assume mon étiquette
voilà je n'en vois pas pourquoi je
l'assumerai passé alors on peut pas dire
la droite alors pour l'appeler comme en
bas pour qu'on a mais moi j'ai jamais
mais comme vous non mais l'ump ça existe
mais femmes et si vous avez acheté votre
problème moi c'est pas ça mais c'est pas
que ça me gêne moi je me suis toujours
reconnu comme étant gaulliste voilà le
gaullisme c'est pas la droite c'est pas
la gauche et tous les français
vous connaissez la volonté de dépasser
ces clivages moi je suis très fier
d'avoir servi à côté d'un président de
la république qui pendant cinq ans
chaque fois qu'il a pris une décision ne
s'est jamais demandé si elle était de
droite ou de gauche mais seulement si
elle servait d'intérêt général de la
france voilà et c'est ça ma conception
de la politique
on était toutes les étiquettes que vous
voudrez je vais finir par une phrase que
j'aime beaucoup de nos amis charles
pasqua
il disait je vais très souvent mais
c'est bien ça
avec l'accent c'est elle avec ouvre à
lévis si la justice sociale c'est de
bosch et bien je suis de gauche si
l'ordre l'autorité
la sécurité c'est de droite et bien je
suis de droite
eh bien ça reflète exactement ma pensée
politique
on vous demandera peut-être une
habitation de gris qui s'y trouvent en
salle et un petit point des actions qui
vont vous demandera peut-être une
imitation de nicolas sarkozy dans la
dernière partie de l'émission qui arrive
merci nadège avec perrine tarneaud donc
de public sénat qui arrive on revient
sur donc l'injustice que vous avez nous
d'en dénoncer je le disais après l'échec
j'ai pas dit si clonage alors vous à
leur parler parce que vous avez une
injustice j'ai pas dit il a construit
mais le 6 mai au soir peut être avez
vous exprimer en fait ce soir là un
sentiment que vous éprouviez
personnellement reggae nos plusieurs
semaines avant même la défaite tran huy
henri guaino
émue aux larmes le 15 mai jour de la
passation de pouvoir entre nicolas
sarkozy et françois hollande l'ex
conseiller spécial du président à
s'échapper sa tristesse et sa déception
sonné par la défaite ils se désespèrent
aussi d'avoir vu son champion incompris
tout au long du quinquennat forcément
mon état d'esprit un peu de tristesse
et puis un sentiment peut-être
d'injustice parce qu'il a il a accompli
quelque chose d'extraordinaire pendant
ces quatre années face à la crise et je
suis pas sûr que tous les français on
est eu pleinement conscience mais voilà
c'est là c'est la démocratie la
démocratie qu'a fait échouer nicolas
sarkozy de peu l'écart s'est resserré en
droitisant la campagne en parlant
immigration et en tentant de séduire
l'électorat du front national
mais le moteur de la campagne a aussi
été sa limite
ce discours lui a permis de faire un
score honorable au premier tour même
s'il n'a pas rempli son objectif qui
était d'arriver devant françois hollande
mais c est aussi ce discours qui l'a
empêché de rassembler au second tour
puisque un certain nombre de français
qui se sont montrés allergique à cette
stigmatisation des immigrés notamment
toujours est il que la stratégie patrick
buisson lors de la campagne l'a emporté
sur la ligne henri guaino et ça n'a pas
dû beaucoup plaire aux petits malraux de
nicolas sarkozy la guerre a été sourde
et discrète entre les conseillers
évidemment à aucun moment henri guaino
ne souhaitez contester la ligne du
président candidat est encore
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on aura du mal à
lui faire contester cette ligne en
revanche on peut parier qu'il n'était
pas très à l'aise avec le discours anti
immigration que nicolas sarkozy a pu
tenir notamment à nantes
lorsqu'il a parlé des vagues déferlantes
de l'immigration c'est un discours qui a
choqué bref lorsque henri guaino parle
de l'injustice faite à son candidat
il parle peut-être à mots couverts de
l'injustice qui lui a été faite
mais un conseiller n'a pas toute sa
liberté de parole un député déjà un peu
plus voilà c'est ce qu'on verra
peut-être dans quelques semaines donc
henri guaino perrine tarneaud rue nous a
rejoint avec corps ça dépend encore une
fois d
nous a rejoint avec également les
contributions de téléspectateurs qui
peuvent intervenir durant cette émission
par le biais de l'application tivi
tchèque de notre partenaire orange
perrine oui bonsoir henri guaino soir
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes prêt à
faire un peu l'analyse de l'échec de
cette élection quand je dois surtout une
analyse qu qu'on veut mais je suis pas
prêt à prendre mes distances vis-à-vis
de ce qu'a accompli nicolas sarkozy ni
pendant cinq ans ni ce qu'il a défendu
pendant la campagne présidentielle
honnêtement je trouve que ces pseudo
analyses rétrospectives aujourd'hui en
quelque chose qui n'est pas elle qui
n'est pas dit voilà donc pourquoi parce
que c'est oui c'est tout ça passait
alors pour ce qui me concerne en tout
cas on n'a pas assez de recul
d'abord sont pas toujours ceux qui sont
le plus démené kiki qui aujourd'hui pour
les critiques les plus virulentes
et puis pour ce qui me concerne j'ai
fait cette campagne je les fêtes
jusqu'au bout je les fait de toutes mes
forces avec toute mon énergie sur des
fêtes pour gagner et si dont j'en assume
tout et si ça n'avait pas été le cas je
serais parti voilà c on a l'impression
que rien ne ressemble à 100% à part soi
même et encore c'est parfois difficile
c'est le mélange d'une petite pme autour
de nicolas sarkozy finalement cette
campagne cette campagne dans lequel le
serment d improvisation à plusieurs
moments fait que le chef de l'état
candidat rebondissait sur sade en
événements ça c'est normal de cette
campagne une histoire les événements je
crois pas que la campagne de monsieur
hollande était très très très bonne très
intéressante non plus je pense que c'est
parce que nicolas sarkozy a fait une
vraie campagne
je pense qu'au delà du ton parfois qui
se joue des meetings
il a soulevé des sujets qui sont des
sujets essentiels et on ne débat
politique ne pourra plus être après
cette campagne qui l'a été avant je
pense à l'europe je pense aux frontières
qui sujet absolument majeur dans la
mondialisation aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de la nation un état à la
république des basses les corps
intermédiaires après il ya les uns
génération des campagnes mais mais
beaucoup de choses importantes ont été
dites après chacun a son style chacun à
sa façon de de s'exprimer mais moi
j'assume totalement ce qu'il a fait je
serais indigné d'avoir fait cette
campagne à voir qui de l'avoir soutenu
jusqu'au bout et dire maintenant
obama n'ont connu qu'un jour cette
campagne ou saas annoncé par akena mais
je sais pas mais en tout cas pas pour
dire que je prends mes distances à
savoir de quoi je vais maintenant qu'on
a perdu finalement comprenez je me
désolidarise mais franchement on vous
voyez dans le reportage qui a précédé un
peu sonné le soir de la défaite comment
vous vous l'avez vécu personnellement
cette défaite ce soir là et dans les
jours qui ont suivi ça je le dis quand
je lui ai vécu avec évidemment une
profonde tristesse parce que c'était un
moment triste avec un sentiment
d'injustice qui balaie les français
orthez test mais moi je les ressentis
comme comme une forme d'injustice parce
que je pense qu'il y assez embêtant
c'est à dire non mais on était juste
dans l'eure dans leur tête ils ont fait
ce qu'ils avaient envie de faire mais
moi j'ai ressenti le résultat final
comme une forme d'injustice parce que
que la sarkozie avait avait fait
énormément pour la france et pour les
français pendant cinq ans notamment
pendant les crises terribles qui se sont
abattues sur notre pays sur l'europe et
sur le monde que sans doute ça a été
sous-estimée par beaucoup de nos
concitoyens
peut-être aussi un peu par les
journalistes voilà donc il faut qu'on
lui a pas rendu si ne vous savez quand
quand la guerre s'achève
il ya des élections en grande-bretagne
et churchill se présentent à la tête du
parti conservateur il est battu il est
battu il n'est pas battu par un génie il
est battu par monsieur clément attlee
chef du parti travailliste il aura
d'ailleurs cette formule cruel une
voiture vide s'arrête devant le 10
downing street
le sua clients des s'en sortent ils
avaient gagné la guerre
c'est l'injustice où la cruauté quel
parallèle amateurs ce n'est pas dit que
c'était sur tille
oui mais parallèle vous savez savez
qu'on n'est pas son jeu ne jamais c'est
ça le principal
j'ai juste ça c'est juste pour rappeler
une vérité éternelle en politique et en
démocratie vous voulez vous faire réagir
et une interview d'un dans la main qui
était un des visiteurs du soir de
nicolas sarkozy on va y revenir tout à
l'heure à la main qui disait dans une
interview au monde ce week-end l'elysée
c'est finalement une toute petite pme
qui court après le temps est ce que
c'est un système qui fabrique de
l'isolément de d'isolement nommé que ça
sera une petite pme oui c'est à dire
c'est pas une énorme bureaucratie ce mas
ans après le temps après les élections
sont pas très longtemps parce que de la
réalité sinon je ne peux pas de la
réalité bon je crois pas du tout à cette
idée de 10 mois je me suis jamais sentie
isolée j'ai vu beaucoup de gens je suis
allé en voir je vais pas rester dans mon
bureau président de la république aussi
alors le président c'est autre chose il
ya quand on est au pouvoir on est tout
seul c'est tout seul devant la décision
les gens s'adressent pas à vous de la
même manière voilà c'est très très
compliqué bien préfet qui racontait son
geôlier il ya très longtemps
il devait accueillir le général de
gaulle il y avait
il avait réuni tous les notables de son
département il y avait beaucoup de
paysans et dépaysante et très en colère
il y avait une crise agricole et les
responsables de l'école était venu le
voir lui disant vous allez voir on va
lui dire au général nous ce qu'on en
pense
très en colère et préfet était
terrorisée à l'idée de cette
confrontation à venir et à l'accueillir
le général blaine une agréable certes et
ça va très mal se passer ils sont très
remontés il est arrivé dans la salle le
général et et puis battu les ons qui
était très en colère enfin pris sur un
simple en général là c'était mon général
des finales de liberté de parole mais si
on arrive c'est là c'est la voilà c'est
l'aspect institutionnel l'emportent
évidemment mais c'est normal il ya un
minimum de respect quand il y en a plus
bien ya plus deux républiques non plus
etc
mais c'est vrai que c'est difficile
difficile de garder un contact avec
l'arrêté je parle du président mais ses
conseillers ses collaborateurs ils sont
pas des policiers présents la république
qui sont sortis de rencontrer des gens
enfin voila moi j'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir vécu dans une tour d'ivoire
pendant cinq ans nous d'être passée à
côté des difficultés à paul sur
l'application tv tchèque d'orange qui
vous demande quel est votre meilleur
souvenir du quinquennat bon il y en a eu
il y en a eu beaucoup j'ai peut-être là
là la passation de pouvoir
l'intronisation en 2007 voilà parce que
c'était le couronnement de beaucoup
d'efforts et beaucoup de travail mais
oui mais je préfère les commencé je
préfère les commencements enfin c'est
comme dans les romans sur ce qu'il ya de
plus génial les commencements ce qui est
bon est ce que vous diriez comme jean
françois copé que françois hollande est
l'homme d'un clan en tout cas une
l'homme d'un temps les hommes donnent
quand il a fait toute sa campagne
faisant je veux faire gagner la gauche
faut que la gauche gagne voilà moi c'est
le pied pour revenir la collation tout à
l'heure moi c'est une c'était une
sémantique qu'une thématique que je ne
comprends pas je sais faire gagner la
droite contre la gauche faire gagner la
france va et parler à tous les français
ce qu'on va assister dans ces prochains
jours à toute une série de nominations
et de remplacement notamment les chefs
des renseignements de la police
est-ce que là c'est une chasse aux
sorcières ou est-ce que c'est finalement
une logique normale comment rendre à 100
dans son public c'est pas la chasse aux
sorcières et c'est pas le spoil system à
l'américaine c'est à dire que il ya une
continuité de l'état d'aider des
services publics de l'administration et
on fait les choses normalement tout
doucement choisissant si possible les
plus compétents moi j'observe c'est que
françois hollande aussi les plus
compétents pour le servir lui non mais
personne ne le sert lui parlons jeu s'en
sert la france ses cinq missions sont de
ses anciens de cette logique on tombe
dans quelque chose que kid absolument
détestable personne ne sert mesure
langue vous servez monsieur sarkozy au
service à un public ému mais c'est très
important
c'est c'est vraiment une je trouve que
c'est quelque chose auquel il faut il
faut absolument s'attacher beaucoup et
nicolas sarkozy vous le remarquerez avec
tous les défauts qu'il a pu avoir et que
vous lui avez volontiers reconnu il n'a
jamais fait ça c'est à dire que il a
nommé des gens venus de toutes origines
politiques de toutes sensibilité le
patron de la sncf c'est l'ancien
directeur de madame aubry
le patron d'eads nv c'est monsieur
juillet le patron de la cour des comptes
c'est un ancien député socialiste je
n'ai jamais vu un gouvernement
socialiste faire cela j'espère qu'on va
le voir
moi je m'en réjouirai par l'ancien
secrétaire général de l'elysée xavier
musca est ce qu'ils valaient à la case
et des poufs à rien ça dépend du
président de la cugt là mais je trouvais
pas ça illégitime et même plus tôt on a
fait un scandale quand il a été question
de nommer mais monsieur muscat et ans
grand serviteur de l'état il a fait
toute sa carrière dans l'état
contrairement à beaucoup de ses
collègues il n'est pas allé gagner des
fortunes dans la banque d'affaires
il a été directeur du trésor il a été
secrétaire général puis secrétaire
général me disait il a toutes les
compétences requises
il ya une profil parfaitement adapté à
cette fonction au président de la
république d'en décider mais franchement
ça serait un acte d'une grande élégance
et très républicain voilà ce que j'en
pense apparemment on n'en prend pas le
chemin d'après les dernières
informations mais on verra ça en tous
les cas le directeur de cabinet de
françois fillon à matignon monsieur
faugères lui a été nommé président de
cnp assurances dont il ya des notions de
vous et ça lui est d'ores et déjà bibis
je salue cette décision ne se faisait à
quelqu'un de très grande qualité qui
méritait d'être de trouver une
responsabilité à sa mesure
merci beaucoup henri guaino merci
perrine prochain preuve par trois ce
sera jeudi en effet une émission
supplémentaire dans le cadre de la
campagne des législatives à notre invité
sera jean vincent placé
le président du groupe écologique au
sénat a très vite
l'excès aujourd'hui je suis en
appréciant sans complexe je parle à tout
le monde je vais tous les ans depuis son
élection on a beaucoup commenté le style
et l'évolution de françois hollande dans
déshabillons-les nous les avons suivis
au jour le jour depuis cinq ans cette
semaine des habits ont donc en tout bien
tout honneur le nouveau président durant
ces cinq années où il s'est peu à peu
présidentialiser déshabillons-les
présentée par hélène risser
c'est mercredi à 18h15 sur public sénat
du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
mais c'est une aberration merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs
mon nom est jack ralite l'habitat ou
perdue dans une cité
il me trouve bien je me souviens quand
je suis arrivé j'avais trois choses dans
ma musette et que je n'ai pas abandonné
pour nourrir mes interventions les
combats auxquels j'ai participé avec mes
collègues
la première c'est que j'étais maire
d'aubervilliers et que c'est une ville
qui ne vous laisse pas indifférent elle
vous marque pour toujours c'est une
ville populaire brûle mais tambre ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième bon
j'avais été ministre c'est une
expérience la santé le travail mais je
pense surtout à la santé on peut naître
dans des milieux qu'on ne connaît pas
résultats à prendre les combats mieux et
puis la troisième chose il ya un appel
qui avait été signé par 174
intellectuels et artistes pour que je
sois sénateurs schena c'est aussi là
semblait intéressante lorsque je trouve
qu'on a plus le temps de travailler et
précisément quand j'étais ministre
j'ai aperçu qu'on aller plus en
profondeur
oui la greffe parle dans la rue devenu
nouvel espace public
la greffe parle comme une insurrection
mentale d'humanité la greffe parle et
récuse les solutions régressive libéral
et étatiste la greffe parle elle et le
peuple dans sa dignité sa diversité sa
responsabilité
la greffe parle pose des questions
humaines plus profonde encore que les
revendications déclaré et réclament tout
simplement la vie
c'était en plein en pleine grande
tourmente
et quand je vois ce que j'utilisais il
ya une vraie hier qu'il est vraiment
qu'on dansait comme tel a dit au gré
d'une interview d'un journaliste tant
que l'argent dominera le monde
il nous en manque rond et je crois que
c'est ça la grande question
elle existe c'est ce jour-là elle
continue d'exister et dans une ampleur
bien plus grande actuellement mais
malheureusement et j'espère
provisoirement c'est l'argent qui dirige
l'argent caché et l'argent visible et
ils n'ont aucune commisération
aucune mais l'enjeu c'était de monsieur
juppé est bien rentré son projet
destructeur quoi et on a gagné
enfin prévisions parce que je me mets
dans ceux qui se battaient mais ils ont
gagné ce qui fait que c'est toujours
possible
c'est complexe mais c'est toujours
nous devions débattre des profonds
problèmes de banlieue
après le conseil des ministres
exceptionnel de lundi ce débat a été
remplacé par l'examen d'une loi
d'exception ultra sécuritaire qui vise
enchaînés toute espèce de liberté
en exagérant toute espèce de danger ce
n'est pas l'ordre dans la république
c'est la république de l'ordre nous
sommes contre votre loi vous ne déclarez
pas la guerre à la pauvreté mais aux
pauvres la banlieue mérite tout autre
chose
excuse moi il reste sarkozy en face il
était ministre de l'intérieur il
écoutait mai et appelle les parties
donc je n'ai pas eu de réponse venu de
lui mais il était là et il était là
après avoir fait sa visite de la
courneuve et avoir parlé du karcher et
il était là après avoir fait sa visite à
argenteuil et avoir parlé des racailles
ou autre vocabulaire
c'est symptomatique quand la réaction
veut taper l insulte le peuple dans sa
diversité et ont dit les gens ont dit
double vie d'une ville
mais je connais des gens de paris qui
viendrait pas en voiture à aubervilliers
en étant convaincu convaincus que leur
voiture disparaîtrait pendant le repas
de famille quand on arrive à mettre dans
la tête des gens de telles aberrations
et quand un jury ainsi une population
populaire vraiment la réplique de têtes
fortes et je sais que là je vais l'effet
de santé et ça m'a touché de l'écouter à
nouveau quand les propositions de
l'adversaire sont polis